This Dnews episode is brought to you by Domain.com
The Holidays are a time when we show generosity
towards strangers and loved ones alike by
giving them the perfect gift.
And science says we suck at it.
Hey there everyone, Julian here for DNews,
lets wrap about presents.
Gifts have become the standard for expressing
love this time of year.
They’re like a tangible way of showing how
well you know someone.
But the problem is apparently we don’t seem
to get good gifts, even if we truly do know
someone like a brother.
Except I don’t know my brother at all.
Sorry for all the crappy gifts, Alex.
The Society of Personality and Social Psychology
released a study on Monday that said sometimes
we give gifts that are tailored to a person’s
traits.
Sounds like it would be a good thing, but
according to the researchers Mary Steffel,
Elanor Williams, and Robyn Laboeuf it can
be disappointing or not very useful for the
recipients.
They noticed that gift cards to specific stores
tend to go unused for much longer than cards
that can be redeemed anywhere.
Instead they recommend giving more flexible
gifts or something that focuses on a person’s
current needs than their more stable traits.
Like I love astronomy and would definitely
appreciate a toy telescope, but I really need
like, a thousand dollars right now.
I fell in with a bad crowd, don’t ask.
Of course, you might think making it clear
you’re picky would get you exactly what
you want, and according to the SPSP report,
you’re right.
That is, if you get a gift at all.
Usually when someone shops for a picky recipient,
they actually put less effort into the gift.
They usually just get a gift card or forgo
getting something altogether.
So you’re more likely to get a gift you’ll
use if you’re picky, but you’ll probably
receive fewer gifts.
Also, c’mon, don’t be a jerk.
Be grateful someone was thinking of you.
So what’s the best gift to really show someone
you care and strengthen a relationship?
As it turns out, it’s probably not an object,
but an experience.
Researchers Cindy Chan and Cassie Mogilner
found that when an experiential gift is consumed,
it evokes a strong emotional response in the
recipient.
And they don’t even have to share the experience
with the gift giver, so they’re the perfect
gift for when you want to get closer to someone
without spending time with them.
While a great gift might only slightly strengthen
a relationship, a bad gift is a great way
to damage it.
Chastity talks about the science behind that
down here.
So would you prefer a material gift or an
experience?
I know I’d love tickets to a hockey game…
hint hint.
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.